[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou virak l'est déjà c'est un programme
qui depuis six mois et qui permet des
acteurs publics et privés de
paris-saclay de travailler ensemble en
vue d' innover au service du territoire
pour une meilleure mobilité des
transports plus performante plus
qualitatif
aujourd'hui c'est la première journée de
la semaine européenne de la mobilité
on a choisi cette journée pour avoir une
journée d' accélération du programme
c'est à dire on a déjà beaucoup d'idées
et maintenant il s'agit de passer à
l'action de faire en sorte qu'ils
deviennent concrètes des projets qui
puissent être des foyers dans les
prochains mois produire des résultats
qu'on puisse évaluer qu'on puisse aussi
financé et puis qu'on s'organise entre
un nombre important de partenaires nous
avons une quarantaine de partenaires
publics et privés on a des start up on a
des industriels on a les trois
agglomérations paris saclay versailles
grand parc saint quentin en yvelines on
a le père paris saclay qui s'occupe de
le développer le plateau de saclay et
tous les projets immobiliers et puis on
a de nombreux acteurs industriels du
territoire qui travaillent dans les
transports dans l'intelligence
artificielle dans la mobilité et c sont
tous des acteurs qui ont travaillé
ensemble ce matin qui ont avancé sur des
plans projets concrets avec des
résultats à la clé pour 2019
et puis cette après midi on a fait un
focus plus globale sur des projets qui
sont déjà existants des projets qui sont
déjà opérationnels on a parlé de
stationnement mutualisé par exemple avec
nous avec nous volent sur le plateau de
saclay des mois prochain et bien il y
aura des possibilités de stationner dans
des parkings privés ouverts au public
pour l'occasion avec une seule appli en
toute simplicité
on a aussi parlé de d'hydrogène à
versailles avec des bornes hydrogène qui
sont disponibles désormais des
expérimentations de bus et de vélos
cargo on a parlé d' information
voyageurs avec viagogo à saint quentin
en yvelines c'est un projet qui permet
d'avoir encore plus d'informations quand
on fait un itinéraire à saint quentin en
yvelines et et bientôt sur l'ensemble du
territoire de paris secret et enfin on
n'a pas réussi de coworking c'est à dire
de bureaux partagés disponibles
pour quelques heures et c'est un sujet
important parce que quand on met deux un
bureau partagé et des salles de réunion
à côté d'une gare de massy-palaiseau
c'est le 30 et 20 avec ce projet là on
permet à des gens qui viennent de
différents endroits de se retrouver
facilement vous permet aussi à beaucoup
de personnes de travailler au plus
proche de chez elle et de limiter leurs
déplacements de garder les meilleurs des
classements et de supprimer les
déplacements des plus contraignants
finalement au quotidien et ce soir on
termine par une dimension plus
prospective avec des intervenants très
divers de l'avion de la recherche d ébut
pour nous parler de comment des
territoires peuvent innover dans la
mobilité quels sont les défis associés
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre
réellement et aux sciences et aux doutes
h un petit peu du buzz médiatique